[Musique]
bonjour a tous voila vous voyez bien je
suis anne marie van vous êtes un espace
autochtone en direct vous l'avez vu sur
facebook on l'a annoncé nous avons
aujourd'hui une invitée une invitée bien
spéciale la ministre des affaires
autochtones du québec madame sylvie
d'amour bonjour un jours merci de nous
retrouver dans notre espace parce qu'on
appelle une question pour vous on a
envie d'en savoir plus sur votre
programme politique et ce qui s'en vient
pour les autochtones et on a posé la
question sur facebook on a demandé aux
gens de vous poser des questions et vous
allez voir il y en a beaucoup
alors on voit des gens va remercier les
gens de les avoir posées et on va
essayer au cours des prochaines minutes
évidemment de passer à travers peut-être
la plupart des questions peut-être
toutes les questions va voir ellis queen
bonjour un jour alors hellich puisque de
votre côté vous touchez toujours aux
enjeux du grand nord dans ce cas-ci
puisqu'on et on va rester au québec
aujourd'hui du nunavik vous aurez vous
aussi des questions pour madame d'amour
oui sont une vie qui épie les enjeux
dans nos plans nos québécois rrq
alors madame d'amour on va commencer
vous êtes députée de mirabel ministre
responsable des affaires autochtones
with avait été nommé par monsieur
françois legault il ya notre collègue
sébastien bovet acquis et le bureau chef
du groupe parlementaire de radio canada
à québec qui a dit que c'était une
surprise de vous voir dans ce poste-là
alors pour commencer est ce que pour
vous ça a été une surprise d'être nommé
dans ce poste par monsieur legault en
fait je pense que tous les ministres
sont surpris de se faire appeler parce
que c'est la prérogative du chef du
premier ministre de choisir l'équipe
mais moi je faisais tellement confiance
en monsieur legault qui choisissent une
l'équipe mais j'avais aucune prétention
d'être ministre de quoi que ce soit oui
quand on m'a nommé ministre des affaires
autochtones peut-être à la grande
surprise de tout le monde moi j'étais
très contente parce que c'est un dossier
auquel j'ai regardé tout au long de mon
premier 4 1 ou l homme
comme député moi et ma collègue lise
lavallée qui est député de repentigny
on regardait aussi sur les dossiers des
femmes disparues les femmes autochtones
disparues
par le fait même donc c'est un dossier
auquel j'ai eu quelques fois à parler au
caucus et oui surprise d'être nommé
ministre par le premier ministre mais
contente de l'être
si vous êtes dans votre zone de confort
quand on parle des enjeux autochtones
tout à fait tout à fait je suis
consciente des enjeux auxquels on fait
face coquelles le monde autochtone fait
face et je suis vraiment la personne je
pense tout humblement de la personne qui
va travailler en fonction de leurs
besoins
alors lorsqu'il a été nommé monsieur
legault a dit le au mois d'octobre qu'il
voulait établir des relations
respectueuses avec les autochtones
comment ça va se faire comment ça se
fait déjà mais on a déjà commencé à
travailler
j'ai eu beaucoup de journalistes qui ont
voulu me poser des questions sur des
sujets qui étaient d'actualité et je ne
répondrai pas aux questions pas par
manque de respect envers les
journalistes
mais je voulais avoir un grand respect
envers les nations et avant de commencer
à parler un journaliste je voulais
commencer à parler avec les grands chefs
alors on a déjà en cacher un travail là
dessus on a rencontré le 16 novembre
dernier
tous les grands chefs à la pnq elle en
fait cette rencontre là avait été
discuté avec le chef monsieur picard oui
de la pnq l1
un rencontre privée avec le premier
ministre par la suite le sage on a
rencontré tous les chefs des grandes
nations et les représentants parce que
c'était pas tous les grands chefs qui
étaient là mais quand même la
représentante est là et on a déjà établi
une base de dialogue dans le respect et
on veut travailler ensemble
donc nous on n'impose rien on n'impose
pas notre façon de faire
on veut la créer ensemble donc la
première rencontre avec le premier
ministre
le message a été
nous venons vous voir organisez-vous
cissé à une table comme à la paix à la
pnq elle rit nous y serons
mais si vous voulez travailler en
groupes individuels
on est ouvert à ça donc maintenant ça
appartient aux nations de savoir comment
ils veulent travailler avec nous on
parle tout le temps de la paix des
braves
une paix des braves parce que le voit
d'ailleurs parlé de la paix des braves
de deuxième et voilà
mais la paix des braves 2 ne sera pas
nécessairement comme la paix des braves
la première qu'on connaît qui est au
dessus du 49e parallèle mais on parle de
ceux des gens du sud oui et il faut
travailler à trouver une entente de
nation à nation
si ce n'est pas une entente globale ça
pourrait être une entente de nation à
nation et nous on est prêt à travailler
dans cette perspective là et donc le
message est lancé
on attend après le travail de la pnq
elle qui doit faire un travail de
s'entendre et de nous on va commencer à
travailler
de la façon dont ils veulent bien
travailler avec nous il vous
reconnaissez toutes ces nations sur le
territoire québécois
oui bien sûr qu'on ressort on
reconnaître au tri nations c'est selon
une histoire ils ont une historique
derrière eux et on doit les reconnaître
on doit les respecter
donc c'est en travaillant comme une paix
des braves numéro 2 oui que on arrivé à
ce haut fait auquel nous on va bien
vivre avec ça notre nation québécoise va
bien vivre avec les nations autochtones
qui sont sur leur très pauvre oui et ce
sont des nations qui souhaitent obtenir
un jour l'autodétermination est ce qu'on
peut penser à ça aussi les ja bah si moi
je pense à la nation crie qui sont
vraiment rendu avec un gouvernement et
qui est très avant ce qui est très
avancé et donc six sept nations l'eau
peut être le modèle pour les autres
nations puis qu'on puisse les aider à
arriver à sceptre de cette façon de
faire au niveau du travail entre nation
à nation
nous on va être heureux de le faire mais
il faut accompagner les nations dans
leur cheminement parce qu'ils sont pas
tous au même niveau alors on peut pas
commencer à dire on va aider que 1 et
pas eu de raison il faut en parallèle
être capable d'aller aider les nations
au où est-ce qu'ils sont selon le rite
selon la tribune en agence sur mais oui
ça peut ça quelles sont vos priorités
parce qu'évidemment là votre table
j'imagine elle déborde la de druyes et
tout le monde veut vous entendre tout le
monde veut savoir ce que vous allez
faire
avez vous établi des priorités en fait
les priorités quand je suis rentré au
savez on a été élu le 1er octobre le 16
octobre assermenté comme député le 18
octobre
assermenté comme ministre et 19 octobre
à 8h30 le matin j'étais au cabinet moi
ma volonté était de 1 au niveau de mon
cabinet avoir une reconnaissance au
niveau du monde autochtone donc 50% de
mon personnel est féminin et même un peu
plus que 50 ont ça et 50% et autochtone
c'est du jamais vu s'est jamais fait et
moi je voulais avoir cette sensible
j'avais cette sensibilité là pour être
capable d'avoir la façon de faire
la façon de penser des femmes
autochtones et être capable d'avoir une
longueur d'avancé
oui pour arriver à ce que moi j'aimerais
faire mais c'est un gain d'une grande
phrase en dire j'aimerais faire
j'aimerais travailler ensemble il est ma
priorité pour moi
booba vous serez surprise chez les
femmes les enfants
donc c'est sûr que l'économie
monsieur legault ces deux objets plus
sensibles se passe beaucoup de choses
mais il faut qu'il se passe quelque
chose mais il faut pas juste regarder et
à être d'aidé
des gens qui ne font que regarder et
laisser passer il faut être dans
l'action mais dans l'action avec eux
qu'on n'est pas là moi je débarque repas
avec mes gros sabots dire vous avez jeu
j'ai la vérité absolue nous allons vous
dire quoi faire
le principe c'est qu'elles résultent on
veut obtenir et comment ensemble nous
allons y réussir nous allons réussir à
obtenir
c'est ma façon de travailler ah oui
alors vous parlez des femmes et des
enfants
les réalités les plus difficiles on
pourrait commencer par parler de la
commission vient parce qu'à la
commission vient il a été énormément
question des femmes vis-à-vis des
services publics québécois
la commission vient arrive à sa fin il
va y avoir toutes sortes de
recommandations d'établi comment vous
allez vous en ligne et par rapport à ça
parce qu'évidemment il va y avoir
beaucoup de recommandations allez-vous
en privilégier certaines plus que
d'autres
avez vous eu l'occasion suivent la
commission vient est de savoir déjà tout
ce qui a été dit oui en fait j'ai suivi
par
facebook oui sur leur site sur le site
oui mais ce que je voudrais c'est que
moi je vais attendre de voir ce que le
commissaire vient vous nous déposer
comme rapport nous allons l'analyser
jdg des souhaits mais je vais attendre
que le dossier soit déposée qu'on est un
ensemble et qu on s approcher
propositions et des recommandations
et oui on devra prioriser certaines
recommandations quand on dépose d'un
rapport on peut pas se mettre à
travailler toutes les recommandations en
même temps pourtant on va en et gérer
mais je pense qu'il va y en avoir qui
vont être beaucoup plus criant que l'on
sait déjà mais que parce que une
commission que ça nous validons celles
ci on doit la travailler maintenant et
c'est urgent et d'autres en parallèle
travail et de les travailler mais à un
rythme plus plus là et donc il ya une
volonté politique alors ah ben oui oui
c'est sûr qu'une volonté politique on
attend près ça pour commencer à
travailler
je dirais moi le souhait que j'ai pas ce
que je vous disais que j'avais un
souhait sur cette commission c'est que
je veux pas j'aimerais pas pour que je
ne pouvais j'aimerais pas avoir des
propositions toutes faites de commandos
wolfach parce que les autochtones ont
une façon de vivre une pensée et il faut
si on veut leur aider il faut travailler
avec la façon et la pensée et nous on
accompagne ces gens-là arriver à un but
arriver à une vous êtes à l'ecoute aller
coûte 2
oui la façon dont te veulent que ce soit
appliquée donc la commission vient
j'espère que le rapport il y aura des
pistes puis des propositions mais aussi
qui est qu'ils aient toujours en tête
que c'est pas les comment va le faire
mais pourquoi on va le faire
et quel but on doit atteindre oui
comment on va le faire on va le
travailler ensemble avec les nations il
faut avoir un but à atteindre
on va l'atteindre mais le commun on le
décidera ensemble
nation à nation et vous allez donc
consulté autant les groupes de femmes
parce que j'en profite pour le dire
viviane michel la présidente de femmes
autochtones du québec pose justement une
question à ce sujet comment secrétariat
aux affaires autochtones mettra-t-il en
oeuvre les recommandations de la
commission vient
ben je ne vous leurrez pas je vais vous
répondre c'est vraiment de travailler de
nation à nation est d'atteindre le but
le but commun mais de l'atteindre de la
façon dont nous allons ensemble
l'atteindre c'est de cette façon là
qu'on va arriver à travailler ensemble
moi je vais pas arriver et dire voici ce
que nous allons faire c'est vous aussi
ce que l'on pourrait faire
oui et vous de quelle façon vous allez
vous intégrez la da et plus le but
ultime c'est on arrive à des ad des
actions qui sont en fait et qui sont
quantifiables
les actions doivent être faits mais il
faut qu'au bout on ait des résultats
oui et ça c'est très important pour moi
aussi vous avez seulement quatre ans là
pour faire tout ça
ouais mais il faut commencer quelque
part oui si on commence jamais si on
avait eu sont toujours dans l'optique de
déranger juste quatre ans moi je
travaille pas pour quatre ans quand un
député ou un ministre travail parce
qu'il ya juste 4 hamas parce qu'il veut
se faire réélire dans quatre heures
désolé de vous dire non j'en ai rien à
[ __ ] si je vais être élu ou pas
parce que pendant les 4 ha oui je veux
travailler et je veux que ce soit à long
terme et que ce soit permanent qu'on
arrête de parler de ça puis qu'on avance
donc mon travail moi le lendemain matin
de la commission vient lorsqu'il aura
déposé de dossier c'est de savoir
comment on peut travailler ensemble
maintenant mais pas pour 4,1
immédiatement immédiat nous et je voyais
d'autres questions que madame viviane
michel à poser à propos de la loi c'est
260 de cette fameuse loi sur la
déclaration des nations unies sur les
droits des peuples autochtones et madame
michèle demande donc aux membres votre
secrétariat va mettre en oeuvre ce
projet de loi c 2 162 fait que j'en
profite pour entendre votre réponse
en fait on en a parlé le 16 novembre
dernier devant les grands chefs où on
doit travailler ensemble encore une fois
m en plus
une forme de de consentement mutuel
parce que moi aussi j'ai une nation
l'élimination à protéger comme eux ils
ont leur nation à protéger donc c'est de
travailler ensemble
il ya un seul je voudrais une seule
chose qui fait défaut c'est le droit de
veto ou là le droit de veto on s'entend
pas nécessairement sur comment on peut
faire mais si si si on peut le
travailler ensemble dans le commande
encore arriver à une une
une façon de penser une façon de vivre
de nation à nation où je convaincu que
ça va aller rapidement
oui et vous dites eux et nous met en
fête et non seulement il va falloir
finir par faire un ensemble nous sommes
tous ensemble
ben moi je le vois autrement je les
respecte nous ne nous respecte et le et
nous ne font qu'un parce que c'est de
nation à nation
moi je ne veux pas être mélangés j'étais
pas le bon terme je veux pas que on
assimile les gens qui confesse que nous
la terre entière est un nous on veut
mais eux ce sont eux il faut les
respecter dans la couture dans leurs
façons de faire dans leur façon de
penser
c'est ce qu' il demain sur le territoire
québécois
mais ils ont un territoire a eu aussi
avec donc oui il faut travailler
ensemble mais dans le respect et dans le
respect de nation à nation
quand je vous dis eux je dois les
respecter oui mais pour eux nous sommes
eux aussi nous y sommes pas nous nous et
je comprends c'est clair oui alors on
parlait on parlait des femmes il faut
aussi parler des enfants et femmes et
enfants on les retrouve aussi au nunavik
où la réalité pour les gens qui vivent
là bas n'est pas évidente du tout et je
pense que hellich pour ça vous avez
plusieurs questions à poser
et puis je vais commencer avec le
système de justice c'est quelque chose
qui préoccupe les dirigeants inuits
depuis des années et puis il dit de plus
en plus qu'elles déploient tous les
rapports qu'ils étaient faits au fil des
vingt dernières années ou qui soulève
les mêmes problèmes ils vivent
exactement le même recommandation mais
dit par exemple l'organisation du québec
que ont ils on est toujours dans une
situation où il ya aucune action qui a
été pris par le gouvernement soit paix
qui soit libéral est ce que les
gouvernements cac à l'étang siens de
prendre des actions concrètes
ma collègue sonia lebel est un
en train de regarder ça déjà j en ai
déjà parlé
elle lit les journaux comme moi elle est
au fait de ce qui se passe et elle est
en discussion avec son cabinet et son
ministère sont en train de travailler
sur ce dossier là donc je peux je vais
pas parler pour elle mais je peux vous
dire que les sensibiliser et que déjà il
ya une attention particulière qui a été
fait à ce sujet est ce que le secteur
peut être un genre de pont pour
s'assurer qu'il ya une action qui va
être rappelé que ça va pas être comme un
autre rapport comme les dernières années
le secret secrétariat des affaires
autochtones vont être le pont pour tous
les ministères monsieur legault le dit
on ne travaillera pu ainsi loup et c'est
tant mieux pour toute la société héli
nations autochtones aussi donc que le
secrétariat des affaires autochtones
pour qu'il soit bien compris pour tous
tous les ministres et tous les députés
de l'assemblée nationale le secrétaire
des affaires autochtones moi je le vois
comme un peu le relais entre les nations
et le gouvernement du québec fecq donc
c'est une
ce n'est pas un ministère comme les
autres c'est le mi6 si le plr le petit
groupe exceptionnel qui est une petite
équipe tout petit mais qui travaillent
d'arrache-pied ça va être le lien entre
tous les ministères et les nations on a
déjà commencé à parler au niveau de la
santé j'ai parlé avec madame mais cannes
si on pouvait avoir ce soit plus rapide
au niveau des actions au niveau du
budget madame et cannes est très ouverte
ils sont en train de regarder ça donc
plein de petits d'aussi qu'on travaille
là en parallèle avec les autres
ministères et le secrétariat des
affaires autochtones est là pour faire
le pont faire le lien avec les nations
dans leurs besoins puis la compréhension
du dossier aussi parce que c'est pas
tout le monde qui a une compréhension
fine d'un dossier autochtone et connaît
les grands enjeux ils vont connaître
aussi les besoins
mais là la finesse entre les relations
doit passer par le secrétariat des
affaires autochtones et tous les
collègues
député et ministérielles sont au courant
de ça je prends la balle au bond en fait
vous avez dit ce n'est pas un ministère
jeff ray kelly qui était à votre poste y
encore quelques mois disait lui
éventuellement il faudrait que ça
devienne un ministère est-ce que c'est
dans l'intention du de la carte de créer
un ministère pour toi parce que c'est un
petit équipes qui travaillent
d'arrache-pied mais moi je veux pas
faire de structure qui est rigide je
faire une structure qui est comme elle
est là elle est parfaite je trouve que
ce cette structure là elle est parfaite
il faut juste bien l'utiliser dans
chacun des autres ministères et cette
structure là parce que parce que je suis
ministre des affaires autochtones mais
je laime ma structure
j'aime m'a soumise qui a une
connaissance profonde du monde
autochtone qui a une équipe aussi des
sous ministres avec l adjoint jusqu'à
tous les fonctionnaires de cette équipe
je les ai rencontrés sont jeunes sont
dynamiques
donc cette structure là elle est
efficace et c'est la meilleure faire un
ministère c'est qu'on vient de confiner
un dossier ou bien nous devons en fait
tous les ministères sont touchés femmes
et santé éducation économie ouais donc
non il faut vraiment juste bien
l'utiliser d'accord alors on retourne au
nunavik ont fait la vie pour la santé la
clis de suicide ou non à des éléments
chute cet automne mais il faut dire que
dans la communauté une sens que quand
mais ça fait pas les manchettes ça se
passe toujours et les gens ne remarquent
pas les gens sont toujours ils ont
beaucoup de difficultés toujours avec ça
est ce que le gouvernement a quelque
chose à court terme pour répondre aux
inquiétudes des gens dans les meetings
maintenant qui en traînant col de vivre
c'est très difficilement jeu contente
que vous me parlez de ce dossier là
parce que j'ai été critiqué de ne pas y
avoir été mais c'est pas par manque
d'intérêt
c'est par manque de billets d'avion et
de place pour me loger on a jusqu'à la
dernière minute on a essayé dit
allez et j'y allais de mon plein gré et
sans avoir été invité il avait lancé
l'appel à tous pour être là pour
seulement entendre ce qu'ils avaient à
dire de voir ce qui se passait là bas
mais il n'avait pas d'attentes envers le
gouvernement
vous regarderez la commission vient ce
que le grand chef d'audi aussi t il le
dit très clairement
mêlez vous de vos affaires on s'en
occupe
alors pour moi en tant que femme en tant
que maire j'ai trouvé ça très dur
d'entendre je comprends le sens de ce
qui veut dire mais en tant que femme
puis dans mon cas j'ai de la misère à
deux mais je veux t d je veux être là
mais si je suis là juste pour écouter
si c'est cela que tu as besoin je vais
écouter si tu veux que je sois là pour
voir je vais y aller aussi mais ça va
être très très dur humainement de ne
rien faire de nous des je veux je veux
faire quelque chose laisse à veut faire
quelque chose de l'esa le secrétariat
des affaires autochtones
julie pour ne pas la nommer elle était
là elle est invitée elle était là
pendant les trois jours mais elle est là
aussi depuis
[Musique]
vingt deux ans j'ai pas je sais pas
depuis le début qu'elle le dossier
meliet avec eux elle travaille avec eux
aussitôt qu'ils on demande
on acquiesce à leur demande on le fait
mais il faut qu'ils aient une ouverture
de leur part moi je pense que la nation
doit comprendre que nous on est là pas
pour leur dire quoi faire mais on est là
pour les aider les accompagner
puis de faire ce qu'ils ont besoin
tc c'est très très difficile comme
humain de se faire dire maintenant des
enfants mais en même temps je le
comprends pas ce probablement que les
expériences auparavant était bon on
débarque on dise que je ne vois pas on
prend nos pratiques québécoises puis on
le sait comme iso puis vous savez on ne
l'avait vite absolue je le comprends que
la nouvelle approche que j'ai comme
comme ministre la nouvelle approche la
nouvelle équipe que j'ai à mon cabinet
et la nouvelle puis le secrétaire des
affaires arterton qui lui prend la
proche du ministre kg de travailler avec
ce ministre là je les comprends qu'ils
aient peut-être les deux sens
mais le message c'est que on est là on
est là pour les accompagner et non pas
pour dire quoi faire et puis une autre
dans tout seul les limites et dans les
communautés nous mettons un temps
souvent qu'au québec on met les
premières nations et les inuits ont un
même panier
mais en réalité le besoin sont
différents et les réalités sont
différentes
est-ce que qu'est ce que votre
gouvernement peut faire pour peut tomber
dans le même piège et puis répondre aux
besoins de canio nations de leur côté
puis les inuits de l'autre ben je vais
vous dire j'ai répété ce que j'ai dit au
tout début
c'est le même principe avec eux s'ils
veulent travailler dehors à eux le
gouvernement du québec est prêt à
travailler avec eux sans les mettre avec
les nations parce qu'ils ont peut-être
usant pour peut-être maison peut-être
ils sont une réalité différente des
besoins différents des façons de faire
différentes
alors c'est à nous à s'adapter et à
travailler ensemble avec donc la porte
est ouverte
ils peuvent appeler au bureau on va
prendre en contre avec eux une rencontre
avec eux on va discuter avec eux on va
voir ensemble qu'est ce qu'on peut faire
puis si c'est leur volonté on sera là
pour les accompagner
il ya une réalité qui est la même pour
tous qu'ils soient première nation ou
inuit
c'est là d'ailleurs ma question est
posée par richard thibault mais aussi
par cindy world msci world vous la
connaissez sûrement aidé doctorante à
l'université du québec en
abitibi-témiscamingue allait charger
cours
la question c'est qu'est ce que votre
gouvernement entend faire pour offrir
aux communautés qui en ont grand besoin
des conditions de vie qui est égale à
celle de tous les autres québécois donc
on parle de l'accès à l'eau potable à
l'électricité au système d'égouts et
surtout hélas ça touche tellement le
nunavik au logement
oui mais en fait c'est des gros dossiers
auxquels il faut s'attarder maintenant
on a déjà commencé à travailler au
niveau 2
avec les grands chefs relais du coeur
des discussions se sont orientés vers sa
carnation besoin d'eau certaines nations
besoin de maisons avec donc on est déjà
au travail à regarder quelles sont les
possibilités
quels sont les avenues possibles pour
justement répondre à ces demandes là qui
sont criantes
il ya toujours le fédéral qui est mêlé
un peu avec le provincial mais il faudra
être très très proactif et suivre le
dossier
j'ai eu plusieurs discussions avec
madame bennett à ce sujet car lille en
effet le oui exactement la ministre
fédérale alan bennett et les consciente
et au courant ou courante que je suis
vraiment intéressé à travailler
rapidement sur ces dossiers dont vous
allez travailler ensemble là dessus
comment ça va sinon vraiment notre bout
de chemin ou du québec puis on va
essayer de faire bonne impression je
veux pas travailler en pression mais
j'ai plutôt travailler en lui disant que
c'est une réalité puisque c'est criant
que c'est un besoin
puis j'ai la ferme conviction que si on
règle une partie du problème serait
réglé au niveau des femmes le si on
règle le logement si on est capable de
d'avoir du logement pour toutes les
familles qu'ils aient une vie normal
qu'ils soient pas 30 à vie dans une
petite maison où il ya peut-être l'autre
les gens sont entassés on vit dans l'
oncle attend que le grand père
bon oui c'est bien d'être en famille
mais des fois on a besoin dans notre
petit coin
moi je pense qu'il va avoir on va avoir
réglé peut-être un problème de de
comportement quand les gens ont pris de
l'alcool puis que vont ils sont un petit
peu
bruyants les enfants dorment pas ils
font la fête
plus tard les enfants sont pris à
dormait dans une même chambre du bruit
le lendemain et ça on ne sent pas apte
aller à l'école
des fois juste de régler un problème
amène des solutions pour d'autres
problèmes et le logement
je pense que c'est criant pour certaines
nations puis il faut s'attarder dès
maintenant le faire à travailler sur ce
12c même aberrant en fait de penser que
tant de gens puissent vivre dans une
maison qu'il soit obligé de faire oui
oui c'est impensable
comme c'est impensable de penser
qu'aujourd'hui encore il ya des
communautés à quelques kilomètres de
montréal pas si loin que ça qui n'ont
pas d'eau potable même somme à
l'électricité il faut s'attarder s il
faut regarder les solutions j'ai la
conviction qu'on va réussir à faire des
pas dans cette direction comme vous
dites je suis là pour quatre à main un
pas à la fois puis je suis convaincu
qu'on va essayer de trouver des
solutions
puis on va en trouver on va régler
certains problèmes à des gens surtout
sur l'eau potable
il faut pouvoir se tissent
c'est élémentaire louis l'ancien
gouvernement avec jeff ray kelly
évidemment avait déjà le dossier entre
les mains ce que les dossiers ont été
passés est ce qu'il ya des solutions que
l'ancien gouvernement avait déjà
commencé à regarder à appliquer qui
pourrait être reprise par vous pour ne
pas recommencer à zéro la victime le
razz quand on rentre dans un cabinet où
il ya des c'est un nouveau gouvernement
qui a rendu vain mot quand je rentre
dans la cabine est ce jour des tiroirs
tout évident
c'est ce que le secrétariat des affaires
autochtones tout est là tout est là les
les
les gestes posés
document les archives sont là pour les
gestes qui sont posés les programmes qui
sont déposées oui mais il ya aussi des
politiques qui sont déposées mais quand
on regarde la politique bain ou ce qu'il
ya de l'homme il ya de l'hommerie une
politique souvent vous l'avez dit tout à
une politique souvent c'est fait pour
quatre ans parce qu'on veut se faire
élire moi je pense qu'il puisse que de
bon dans la politique jean richard
comment ferais pas un travail qui a été
fait ce serait d'être malhonnête envers
les gens qui se sont assis autour de la
table puis qui ont travaillé fort pour
arriver à une politique
je vais prendre la politique mais je
vais aller au plus criants puis au plus
je serais peut-être pas la politique au
complet mais je vais aller voir les
chapitres ou là ben oui ça c'est
important qu'il faut le faire maintenant
prioriser peut-être autre chose dans la
politique mais de prioriser en fonction
de la nation en fonction des besoins
criants
alors justement qu'est-ce que l'ancien
gouvernement a laissé que vous pourriez
déjà appliquée king il ya une politique
sûr il ya une politique attendait au
niveau de la culture qui à mon avis j'ai
déjà dit la sominice de ma collègue
pendant une discussion corrida je la
trouve un peu frileuse
il ya mahdi ben vous êtes bienvenu à
venir voir qu'est ce qu'on pourrait
faire à ce niveau là il ya une politique
aussi qui a été déposée je me cherche le
terme le titre
j'aurais dû vous l'apporter sur une
politique qui sortit le dernièrement
dernières années de deux du gouvernement
libéral que j'ai regardé je pense que
d'autres choses qu'on peut faire de plus
criant que dans cette politique là donc
mais ça sera avec déduction comme on dit
avec les nations du national sion que
nous dise dans ma nation à moi voici la
priorité donc on va travailler en
fonction de leurs besoins de leurs
demandes
alors il ya beaucoup de priorités il y
en a tout plein
oui moi je pense qu'il faut pas penser
que nous on a la vérité sur les communs
et comment on peut faire qu'est-ce
qu'ils ont besoin mais avec les nations
à travailler ensemble ne pas travailler
en silo je pense que ça va aller plus
vite avalées ça va être plus efficace on
a reçu beaucoup de questions je le
disais les gens ont des questions même
des fois très pointu la très précises
entre autres celle de encore là je
reviens madame oil cindy walkie dit
j'aimerais savoir si madame la ministre
une stratégie pour agir efficacement sur
la sur représentation carcérale des
femmes autochtones du québec qui ne fait
qu'augmenter
et c'est vrai qu'on le voit dans les
dents les chiffres une représentation 3
7% en 2006 2007 on est rendu à presque
10 % et il semble que ce soit le double
des hommes autochtones les femmes
autochtones en prison comment on peut
faire pour remédier à ce problème qui
est de plus en plus graves puisque les
chiffres continuent à augmenter
moi je vous relancerez un ou dix ans la
question suivante comment on peut faire
ensemble remédier à cette suite qui moi
pour dire comment faire comment on peut
faire pour que les femmes autochtones
combat ce ratio l'eau c'est eux
si cette caylar nation c'est les femmes
qui vont décider ensemble d'un commun
accord avec le québec qui moi je vois
les accompagner dans sa maison toutes
les justices on touche la santé
on touche la famille ont touché des
enfants
donc comment on peut faire pour diminuer
ce que le but à atteindre c'est de
diminuer
comment on va faire travailler grosse
bourde
oui pourquoi attendre un après l'autre
mais il faut le faire ensemble
c'est sûr qu'il ya des choses qu'on doit
faire au niveau du gouvernement au
niveau des lois mais moi je suis d'avis
qu'une femme ou un homme peu importe
quand l'être humain a fait un geste ci a
fait un geste d'une violence et que sa
salle l'emmène aller en prison
ben c'est la même violence convient nous
dans notre nation comme québécois fait
que les peines doivent être les mêmes
donc si il ya quelqu'un qui est
autochtone qui fait un geste qui doit
aller en prison ou qui doit avoir des
représailles judiciaires ben c'est la
même chose pour nous les québécois
oui peut-être des pourcentages plus
élevé chez les femmes il faut savoir
pourquoi il faut savoir comment et quel
est le but qu'on veut atteindre ensemble
s'ajuster culturellement aussi pour
représenter la réalité des autochtones
qui n'ont pas la même nécessairement la
même façon de penser de voir les choses
et d'agir est-ce que culturellement on
va vous aider aussi à vous ajuster à ce
qui attend ces gens là et à leurs désirs
c'est sûr que je suis aidé par mon
équipe qui est moitié autochtone je suis
aussi aidé par le jeune meneur arrière
des affaires autochtones qui les
côtoient tous les jours qui voient ces
gens là qui leur parle tous les jours
donc oui je suis très sensibilisés je
suis aidé je suis bien entouré et j'ai
une grande écoute et je suis capable de
m'adapter avec les gens auxquels avec
lequel je travaille je travaille
oui avec donc
une grande ouverture pour ça oui encore
là il faudra toujours avoir en tête que
quand quelqu'un fait un geste qui est
pas correct mais ça prend des
représailles c'est pas parce que le lion
et le geste a été posé parce qu'il ya
des antécédents
nous aussi on a des gens qui posent des
gestes qui ont des antécédents puis
passe par la justice aussi mais ça c'est
la fin je dirais la fin d'une d'un livre
mais pour bien écrire le livre pour
avoir une bonne fin d'un bon livre
il faut commencer dès la naissance de
l'être humain sa vie de jeune sa vie
d'adolescent sa vie de jeune adulte sa
vie d'adulte et on aurait une bonne fin
de ce livre là avec donc faut peut-être
y paraît mais il faut plus s'attarder à
comment les gens vont bien vivre pour
avoir une belle fin de ce livre heures
natacha tanguay on parlait de votre
bureau avec de plus en plus
d'autochtones qui donc ont été engagés
par le secrétariat aux affaires
autochtones et moi je m'excuse c'est moi
qui les engage
c'est vous qui les avez ya six mois le
secrétariat non pas du tout ce bon choix
moi d'accord donc quand vous êtes arrivé
au secrétariat des autochtones y en
avait pas beaucoup
le bureau était vide en fait le cabinet
faut séparer les choses il aurait créé
taris des affaires autochtones qui de
gouvernement gouvernements ne changent
pas oui exact et le cabinet du ministre
de la ministre le cabinet changent
complètement à moins d'avoir des gens
compétents qui sont vives et qui ont une
compétence et que
parce qu'il ya beaucoup de cabinets au
niveau du gouvernement de la coalition
du québec qui a des gens qui viennent du
parti québécois il ya des gens qui
viennent du parti libéral oui s'ils ont
la compétence on change pas les gens moi
quand je suis arrivé le cabinet et j'ai
dû conduire au cabinet et par cette
malchance heureux changement dans les
airs mais ça m'a permis de mettre
d'installer ma vision puma volonté
d'avoir des autochtones un nom de moi
alors c'est 50% est ce que
éventuellement ça pour être 100%
d'autochtones au secrétariat
la secrétaire à 19 pour le cabinet ça
pourrait être une volonté c'est d'avoir
du sang pour sang le secrétariat des
affaires autochtones ben c'est comme
dans n'importe quelle
ministère ils ont des pourcentages à
suivre je pense qu'ils les respectent
je pense que au secrétariat d'une petite
équipe mais il ya peut-être 10% qui sont
autochtones mais en fait quand ils
reçoivent les cv ce que madame thomas
m'a confirmé la sous-ministre juillet
posé la question et sa réponse était
vraiment moi ça me convenait le web
c'était la réalité c'est que c'est pas
non plus 100 % des cv qu'elle reçoit qui
sont autochtones
parfois il y en a pas du tout donc elle
travaille avec les cv paix dans la
fonction publique le meilleur quand même
une certaine réalité qu'elle connaît
depuis l étude ainsi les gens sont
compétents qu'eux elle regarde pas
nécessairement quelle nationalité les ou
porte ses cadres dans les fonctions
puisqu'il ya les aptitudes pour le faire
mais je sais qu'il ya sûrement des
autochtones mais peut-être qu'ils vont
pas non plus déposé oui justement j'ai
une question là dessus de natacha
tanguay qui dit j'aimerais connaître les
statistiques d'emploi des autochtones au
sein du gouvernement du québec
ce n'est pas la réponse à ça faudrait
que je la demande puis je pourrais vous
voyez venir avec ça mais je sais que
dans le secrétariat des affaires
autochtones
il ya un petit pourcentage dans mon
cabinet c'est 50% mais dans l'ensemble
de la fonction publique j'ai pas la
réponse donnée et natacha tanguay
demande aussi quelles sont les
initiatives en place pour sensibiliser
et former les fonctionnaires aux
réalités autochtones
il ya des jeunes formations qui est
donné qu'une formation qui connut au
secrétariat des affaires autochtones que
on c'est bon on a discuté ma chef de
cabinet mme alice picard et marie josé
tomas qui m'a sous ministre lors de
notre dernière rencontre on a discuté de
la possibilité que cette formation soit
donnée à tous les ministères
une fois de plus par ce milieu des
nouveaux qui sont arrivées de nouveaux
fonctionnaires
oui on va aussi faire l'étape 2 des
cabinets des ministres et ensuite les
ministres auront une mini formation là
pour ça que qu'est-ce que le secrétariat
des affaires autochtones et le
autochtones sont eux qu'on appelle mais
elle existe déjà elle est déjà donné
cette formation là elle est adaptée elle
existait donc déjà avant votre arrivée
oui je sais pas si elle a été donnée aux
et ma volonté c'est que ça va se faire
oui oui et est-ce qu'elle sera est ce
qu'elle sera enrichie elle est toujours
actuellement est toujours
oui où il est toujours le terme au goût
du jour les toujours actualisée en
fonction des réalités que les nations
vivent et la formation est donnée aux
besoins ou à la demande puis moi j'ai
fait la demande
et c'est bien bien reçu dans le bassin
s'organisent pour justement que tout le
monde sache ce qu'est ce qui se passe
oui on n'a pas le temps de parler
d'éducation encore alors je vais y aller
avec une question qui vient de prudence
à nice elle est la directrice associée
du collège des premières nations le
collège qui una est en fait elle demande
que compte faire votre gouvernement pour
soutenir la seule institution
postsecondaire des premières nations au
québec dont qui est qui mena et qui est
donc pas très très loin d'ici d'ailleurs
du côté d'odanak qu'est-ce que vous avez
l'intention de faire pour soutenir cette
institution là mais en fait la même
chose que quelques-uns j'ai moi je pense
que je connais pas ce dossier le contest
600d des embûches ou qu'ils ont des
besoins parce que j'ai à venir jusqu'à
d'abord eu aucun appel de ces gens là
avec dans le sillon une problématique
ils peuvent toujours appelé mon bureau
de me faire plaisir de les rencontrer
mais ce que je peux vous dire dans
l'ensemble
pas nécessairement que pour relever mais
dans l'ensemble la première chose que
monsieur legault parle avec les grands
chefs
c'est oui de l'économie mais la première
chose dont on parle c'est de l'éducation
pour lui tous les enfants je dis bien
tous les enfants tous les petits êtres
humains oui on en a qui vivent au québec
doivent avoir la même chance que tous
pour arriver à avoir une bonne éducation
une bonne santé et avoir un bon travail
donc l'éducation c'est primordial pour
monsieur legault peu importe le petit
être humain québécois ou de nation
autochtone ouais même si la réalité pas
évidente pour tous non plus quand on est
dans une communauté éloignée
déjà juste envoyer des professeurs pour
aller travailler en communauté reculer
c'est pas évident non plus donc on le
voit il ya quand même une disparité
entre ce qu'on peut obtenir comme
éducation ici en plein coeur de montréal
et où très loin dans une communauté mais
il faudra adapter selon leurs besoins
mais seulement leur mode de vie aussi
parce que c'est pas nécessairement nos
façons de fac sont peut-être les
meilleurs moi je vois j'ai vu une jeune
femme en bas âge qui avait déjà trois
enfants très difficiles pour elle
d'aller sur un banc d'école tous les
jours avec ses trois enfants
comment on peut faire pour qu'elle
atteigne son secondaire 5
atteigne qu'elle étudie dans un métier
qu'elle aimerait faire tout en gardant
en tête que c'est une maman de trois
enfants
donc il faut adapter c'est ce cours là
il faut adapter selon le besoin de ce
qu'elle a et elle n'est pas la seule il
y en a plusieurs jeunes femmes
autochtones qui ont plusieurs enfants
qui aimerait retourner à l'école il va
falloir qu'on regarde pas juste les
structures mais la façon de faire tapis
pour arriver à un but que ces gens ne
soient scolarisés autre question qui
arrive
je voulais dit les questions étaient
vraiment vraiment très exigeants lieu de
la part des gens qui nous écoutent cipi
flamand c'est le vice chef de la
communauté attikamek de manawan il dit
la question est longue alors comment
votre gouvernement mettra tine en place
une nouvelle relation de nation à nation
avec les communautés des premières
nations
ça c'est une de ces questions il parle
également de la déclaration des nations
unies on en a parlé un petit peu plus
tôt mais si on revient à cette première
question là comment est-ce que le
gouvernement va mettre en place cette
relation de nation à nation
vous l'avez expliqué un peu plus tôt
mais concrètement comment ça se déroule
en fait on n'atteint que quand nous on a
lancé les violations d'invitation a
lancé l'idée
comment vous voulez travailler nous on
est prêt à s'adapter à vous vous voulez
une table commune on est là vous voulez
travailler de nation à nation
on sera là vous voulez travailler deux
communautés à nation on sera là donc
c'est à eux le monde suite à la balle
est dans le camp des nations et c'est à
eux de décider comment ils veulent
travailler
donc on est ouvert l'appel est lancé
maintenant c'est à eux à venir vers nous
il y en a certains qui sont déjà qu'ils
ont déjà comme un vélo du travail de 1 à
puis on commence à travailler de cette
façon là moi je suis je suis la porte
d'entrée pour le gouvernement
donc je reçois des grands chefs qui
viennent un chacun leur tour me
rencontrer me donner la priorité les
grands projets qu'ils aimeraient avoir
dans dans leur territoire
et puis moi je monte soudan
dans mon conseil des ministres puis on
regarde avec monsieur legault avec
l'équipe alentours de monsieur le groupe
parce que des gens qui sont attitrés aux
autochtones qui sont tout près de
monsieur legault donc on travaille
vraiment là en concertation pour un
incident que ça que le processus
s'enclenche pour cette nation là donc on
est prêt à travailler
monsieur legault a une totale ouverture
vers les autochtones parce qu'on regarde
ce qui se passe avec le dossier a pu y
attend ce moment et on dirait qu'au
contraire chacun reste sur ses positions
les autochtones wijk veulent que le
projet aille de l'avant
du côté de votre gouvernement on n'a pas
envie que ce projet-là et de l'avant en
fait là vous dites le projet appui at je
me suis fait reprendre plusieurs fois
fait je veux dire comme il faut à vous
le ferez le grand respect du grand chef
mécanisée ses appuis il faut prononcer
appui d'accord alors le projet à
footnote est un beau projet et qu'un
grand projet mais la problématique c'est
que on est en surplus d'énergie
oui oui et si on veut parler et ça
commence par ce dossier
si on veut parler de respect de nation à
nation
je suis très très respectueuse de cette
nation mais moi aussi j'ai un grand
respect pour la mienne ma nation alors
si pour eux ça la porte de l'argent et
que pour moi ça en apporter aussi demain
matin on par le projet mais pour le
moment en surplus d'énergie
nous on va perdre énormément d'argent ma
nation va perdre beaucoup d'argent alors
moi je suis pas mandaté par ma nation
j'ai été élu comme les grands chefs de
cette nation là les divisent noms ont
été lus
eux ils veulent travailler pour leur
nation moi je travaille pour l'avenir
nîmes
donc c'est pas un projet pour le moment
auquel on doit s'attarder
parce que ma nation serait en reste avec
ça on perdrait énormément d'argent
le projet on quand on a rencontré tous
les chefs
on leur a expliqué de cette façon avec
grand respect on aura dit et c'est un
ans
est un engagement que monsieur logo a
pris cette soirée là je me suis appuyé
de quelle date
je pense que le 10 décembre qu'on les a
rencontrés ou avait un petit peu avant
le 10 on leur a dit aussitôt qu'on aura
plus de budget ou qui aura un projet
énergétique qu'on devra travailler le
projet appui de sera le premier et c'est
un engagement qu'il a pris devant tous
les chefs
je le redis aujourd'hui parce que c'est
un engagement qu'on va faire le projet
est bon le projet est excellent c'est
une très bonne idée ça peut être un
projet structurant pour la communauté
innu et qui va aider cette communauté
qui est bondé la communauté mais en
attendant comment on peut faire pour les
aider
quelle honte projet on pourrait
accompagner ces gens là où quelqu'un ce
serait leur projet je puis on s'en dire
ben parce qu'on vous a aidé on met le
projet appui de côté non non le projet
appui tout sera toujours là mais comme
on peut faire entre temps pour aider
cette nation là
on est encore très ouvert autre question
et là on arrive vraiment sur autre chose
c'est simon lebel qui pose cette
question là comment retrouver nos droits
lorsqu'on est de descendance autochtone
parce que là on l'a vu au québec il ya
beaucoup de gens qui disent avoir de la
descendance autochtone en fait avoir des
ancêtres autochtone beaucoup de gens
d'ailleurs dernièrement qui se sont dits
métis aussi métissé comment est ce que
vous allez commencer en avons retrouvé
les droits pour ceux qui doivent les
retrouver
moi je dois vous avouer que je me suis
pas attardé à ceux du tout c'est pas
dossier je suis pas qu'il n'est pas
important mais je me suis attardé depuis
le 18 octobre à travailler sur des
dossiers sur les femmes violentées et
les femmes disparues les enfants qui
l'écrit aux lésés ces débris aux rites
et auxquels je me suis attardé et ce
dossier là très honnêtement non il est
pas je me suis pas attardé brennan et je
dis pas que je le ferai pas mais pour le
peu temps auquel je suis depuis que je
suis ministre j'ai vraiment pas eu assez
de temps pour regarder ce dossier là je
pourrai pas vous répondre
une autre question qui allaient dans ce
sens à d'ailleurs vous n'y répondrai pas
non plus c'était de jean-françois gagnon
quand est ce que les nations métis du
québec auront leur accréditation
quand seront elles reconnu auprès du
gouvernement donc la pensée la même
réponse désolé mais en fait comme je
vous dis y'a tellement de priorité au
niveau des dés
nation autochtone que je vais m'attarder
aux priorités criante et non pas six
puissances en plus avec tout mon respect
envers ces gens là qui se sentent
peut-être un peu mais j'espère qu'ils
vont comprendre que qui me laisse un
petit peu arriver je vais essayer de
trouver du temps pour eux la pop star
oui oui alors il ya plusieurs autres
questions que je ne vous ai pas posé en
fait ce qu'on va faire on va prendre
tout de suite l'invitation nous vous
rêvez vit-on sur ce plateau dans un oeil
dans la case et vous aurez un an pour
aller sur le terrain va les rencontrer
les gens pour discuter pour amener
évidemment des solutions à bien des
problèmes
et dans un an on se donne rendez-vous et
on fait le bilan de ce qui s'est passé
depuis un an parce que c'est vrai que
c'est important quatre ans va passer
vraiment vite et on veut voir dans un an
déjà où vous en êtes rendrai faut que
tout le monde soit conscient que nous on
vient d'arriver
on a déjà fait notre proposition aux
nations maintenant ça sera bien à eux
aussi de vous dire à quel moment ils
nous auront répondu parce que il faut
toujours validé le temps de les changer
qu'on arrivait il faut valider aussi
leur demain c'est à dire il faut
regarder à quel moment ils vont faire
leurs demandes
parce que si vous mourez invité dans un
an puis j'ai pas grand réponse à vous
donner
probablement que ce parce que j'attends
encore après
la table de travail ou la table de
travail ne s'est pas formé ou moi je
suis très impatient ne m'ingère de
commencer à travailler
j'aime à grandmont grand des fous qui
est une grande qualité c'est
l'impatience surtout dans ces dossiers
là alors je lance l'appel à tout le
monde
vous avez eu l'invitation de mon
gouvernement maintenant nous on est en
attente pour rencontrer ces gens-là
mon bureau est toujours vert je suis
disponible pour aller dans les régions
quand je suis pas malade
quant à louis alain garnier jeu capable
d'avoir un avion à l'âge comme j'étais
tellement malade vous voyez encore ma
voix qui est un peu enrhumé beaucoup de
fièvre et je remplaçais ma collègue en
environnement au conseil des ministres
et là j'ai essayé de regarder comment je
pouvais atterrir à les leur revenir
donc il y avait vraiment une grande
difficulté j'ai contacté la grande chef
pour lui une jérôme non c'est pas la
grande chef s'est lâché oui moi j'ai
contacté la grande chef qui madame peur
ce oui mais c'est madame jérôme qui
n'était pas très contente que vous ne
soyez pas venu ouais ouais et et c'est
dommage ça y'a peut-être pas eu le
message de madame personne mais moi j'ai
appelé la grande chef et lui dire que
j'étais vraiment désolée de ne pas y
avoir été de ne pas y aller elle
comprenait ma voix qui était à roue et
qui tant aimée c'est à dire et qui je
lui racontais un peu ma petite péripétie
avec mes petits-enfants qui me
comprenait à trouver partir irradié
m'ont dit que je vous comprends
tellement méchant mais plus en forme en
garderie il m'aime beaucoup une colle
puis me donne le rhume puis la grippe
puis bon tout s'en suit oui c'était pas
par manque de volonté c'était vraiment
parce que j'étais incapable au niveau de
la santé au niveau des dix rencontres
que j'avais aussi à québec mais on s'est
entendu la grande chef et moins que dès
fin janvier début février
on aurait une rencontre que j'ai demandé
à mon cabinet tout de suite après mon
appel avec la grande chef de prendre à
un rendez vous avec eux pour aller
chez eux parce que je sais pas si vous
ne saviez mais moi je viens de val-d'or
je suis venu au mans dans abitibi donc
je connais très bien
les communautés là bas j'ai encore de la
famille là je vais à chaque année dans
des ehpad l'inconnu puisse pas s'ils ont
accès au val d'or notre agence est
superbe ou allez-y oui les collègues
rentrent de val-d'or lanoëlle ya un parc
à traverser mais c'est vrai que marié
beau le parc la vérendrye et très très
beau et surtout l'été du vin des routes
sont quand même très très belle aussi
donc vous étiez déjà les dans les
communautés autochtones je connais les
communautés où je suis déjà quand
j'étais petit mais je connais les les
gens qui habitent le d'ailleurs une
maison que le club veut un garage à val
d'or le garage shell pour ne pas le
nommer connaissait très bien monsieur
abel bosum avant qu'il soit grand chef
c'est un client chez mon oncle et qu'ils
connaissaient très bien donc non ces
postes est pas inconnue totale chez nous
la réalité autochtone alors vous allez
faire une pause pendant la période des
fêtes vous aurez le temps de me reposer
qu'est ce qui vous attend à partir du
mois de janvier vous l'avez dit vous
aurez cette rencontre avec la grand chef
oui mais sinon est-ce qu'il ya déjà des
dossiers prioritaires sur lesquels vous
allez vous lancer dès le mois de janvier
en fer jat1
avec grande impatience les deux rapaces
le rapport de la commission viellard par
enquêtes nationales
elle est chargée des femmes
malheureusement ça va sortir seulement
qu'en septembre
oui mais entre temps on est capable de
faire des gestes j'ai demandé à mon
équipe à mon cabinet et à la sous
ministre et son équipe de regarder à ce
qu'on puisse faire une tournée pour
aller sur place allaient rencontrer les
gens aller
voir la réalité de voir comment on peut
travailler ensemble de quelle façon on
peut
accélérer les processus
ça c'est danser dans mes premières mais
premier geste que je vais faire le début
de l'année oui alors pour le fada c'est
vrai que le rapport va arriver beaucoup
plus tôt au rapport final pour la
commission vient ce sera au printemps
des recommandations et on a déjà
quelques unes sur nos tables donc déjà
ça vous permet donc lâché exactement le
processus
ouais sylvie d'amour merci beaucoup
merci de les passer dans le studio
l'espace autochtone rendez vous est pris
donc dans un an
merci merci beaucoup de m'avoir un merci
merci merci et licha merci beaucoup
et merci à vous tous qui l écoutent la
semaine prochaine nous allons faire une
table ronde sur l'appropriation
culturelle vous savez que kanata et
présentée à partir de demain à paris
donc nous allons en discuter avec
plusieurs intervenants la semaine
prochaine portez vous bien au revoir
[Musique]